hey this is sort of weird this has gone
now beyond the potential even of parody
because it's as bad as any parody of a
president could ever possibly be Donald
Trump gave an interview to the Daily
Caller during which he defended voter ID
requirements by arguing that if you go
buy cereal at the grocery store you have
to have a photo ID we are without a
doubt in an idiocracy at this point and
it's exceeding accurate description by
the English language at this point
Donald Trump again during this interview
was asked about the recounts going on
for the midterm election Florida
supposed voter fraud Trump recently
saying that he thinks people voted went
home put on disguises and went back to
vote again and here is a quote from this
Daily Caller article about what Donald
Trump said the Republicans don't win and
that's because of potentially illegal
votes Trump complained when people get
in line that have absolutely no right to
vote and they go around in circles
sometimes they go to their car put on a
different hat put on a different shirt
come in and vote again nobody takes
anything it's really a disgrace what's
going on if you buy a box of cereal you
have a voter ID Trump continued they try
to shame everybody by calling them
racist or calling them something
anything they can think of when you say
you want voter ID but voter ID is a very
important thing so we're going to talk
about the actual comment in a second
here what's even more stunning is that
the Daily Caller published this section
of the interview without any comment
about the absurdity of what Donald Trump
is claiming without any indication that
during the interview they even thought
to push back against what Trump is
saying with something even as simple as
mr. president what do you mean when you
buy cereal you need a voter ID what a
what exactly did you mean by that
obviously you do not need an ID to buy
things at the supermarket if we want to
sort of play the can we possibly be as
charitable as possible game which at
this point I don't know why we play that
with Trump but let's play it
if you pay with a check it's possible
that the supermarket might have a policy
of saying all check payments need to be
accompanied with a photo ID
maybe I searched around and this is
actually not the first time that Donald
Trump suggested this check out this
video clip from think this was late July
early August at a rally you know if you
go out and you want to buy groceries you
need a picture on a card you need ID you
go out and you want to buy anything you
need ID and you need your picture what's
even funnier is that after Donald Trump
said this press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders had to defend it and she
pretended that obviously Trump was
talking about if you buy alcohol you
need an ID to prove that you're 21 and
notice what one of the reporters says to
her when she tries to make this case I'm
not sure I'm not sure why that matters
either certainly if you if you go to a
grocery store you buy beer and wine
you're certainly going to show your ID I
don't think that he's not saying every
time he went and he said when you go to
the grocery store I'm pretty sure who's
been to a grocery store that's purchased
beer or wine has probably had to show
their ID if they didn't and that's
probably a problem this is just the best
Sarah Huckabee Sanders says well listen
if you buy beer or wine you do have to
show your ID to which the reporter says
Trump claims he's never had a drink in
his life so what that doesn't make any
sense and she says well no I don't mean
him specifically just if someone Pat
went and bought alcohol they would have
to show ID isn't this just a new low of
idiocy well I actually have a different
theory so in the Daler Daily Caller
quote he said that if you buy a box of
cereal you have a voter ID not that you
need a voter ID that you have a voter ID
so that suggests to me that the voter ID
comes free with the cereal it's like the
surprise inside
you know whenever you buy curiam instead
of
yeah root loops a voter ID comes along
with it and I guess it has your picture
and everything you need yeah I guess
that makes sense if you're looking to be
identified as Tony the Tiger when you go
vote which I don't know if that's
actually something that Trump would be
in favor of or not this has just gotten
too stupid and part of this obviously is
that Trump just doesn't shop for
groceries he never has that's not an
excuse though if you're the president
just because you haven't ever shopped
for groceries doesn't mean that you're
excused when youth they say things as
stupid as hey listen voting for IDs for
voting makes sense because we already
have IDs for buying cereal at the
grocery store unbelievable the depths to
which we've sunk one of today's sponsors
is Skillshare which is an amazing online
learning community that offers thousands
of high-quality classes on almost any
topic first 500 people who click the
link under this video will get two
entire months of totally free access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
they've got classes on everything from
design video editing photography
business technology cooking meditation
even classes on personal productivity I
know you'll be able to find something on
Skillshare that fascinates you or even
something that will help you in your
everyday life classes are taught by real
people who care about what they're
teaching I just took a really great
class on more advanced video editing
techniques the david pakman show is
giving you two months of free access to
every class they offer when you click
the link under this video
think about everything you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep access to
every class on Skillshare for under ten
bucks a month one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of skill share but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up